he covers the National Football League
for Yahoo Sports and was talking about
the dates by which a the NFL is thinking
of having mini camps and those dates are
right from the middle of June to the end
of June said where there's lots to talk
about right here with Charles Robinson
of Yahoo how are you sir I'm doing well
I am doing fine so let's start off you
heard our conversation or how much you
were listening in or when you you try
are you you're you called in about this
fourth and 15 from the 25-yard line
replacement if you will of the onside
kick which I dig I would like a lot what
are you hearing about it Charles
I I heard that Albert is correct that it
is not a it is an untimed down and that
that was a tweak that was actually
adjusted this morning and I think Albert
actually reported that that they made
the changes this morning okay
you raised a question though that I
actually didn't know you and I thought
yeah is that you know if is it in a
situation where you would normally award
a first down do you simply walk off the
yardage and repeat the down and I
actually don't know the answer to that
how about that I raised it and I said
that I thought I don't I don't that's a
good question I don't know if that I
don't know what they were doing that
Charles that's what I do for profession
is ask good questions I you know I don't
know the answer to it you know I'm
trying to look up the language while
we're talking right now because I got
that email in my NFL email inbox today I
don't know if it's really spelled out in
this rule yeah you took me from prepared
to completely unprepared you know what I
mean it's it's really you know I I just
I like the idea though too is that you
know I as the team that's thinking about
doing this fourth and 15 from the 25
even even up I'm thinking about stealing
a possession because I'm I think fourth
and 15 I've got it you know we've got
Andy Reid
the show later this week and I'm sure
he's you know he's already come out and
said we've got a guy can do fourth and
15 pretty well oh you know but if let's
just say somebody gets flagged for
taunting on defend where they're angry
they get they you know they they they
shove somebody after having a something
scored on them now you're moving the
line of scrimmage for this try up to the
40-yard line as opposed to the 25 which
right you know a field position is not
that much concern for me I'm gonna go
for it
you know that's man I think anything if
there's another another flag in play and
and it's just the 25 yeah it absolutely
makes it more enticing and Andy's the
perfect guy to talk to because I know I
mean Pat mahomes is clearly salivating
he's already taken to when this first
got rolled out you know everyone saw the
tweet where he clearly was interested in
this play felt like this was an
advantageous rule adjustment for them
though Charles Robinson of Yahoo here on
the Rich Eisen show you think it's gonna
pass again this voters tomorrow do you
think this works I think it will because
they're tweaking it like I don't I don't
um when they make on-the-fly adjustments
so I saw what Albert had had reported I
texted somebody today's is a curation
yeah said I I do I think they you know
they changed it to make it a an untimed
down and typically when they make
adjustments like that it they feel like
it has you know it's got momentum and
and they're they're kind of checking
we're doing a pressure check to see
what's the what are the holes here what
are the loopholes what are things that
that could be unintended consequences
and can we get those taken care of
before this goes to a vote so I actually
think that week makes it more likely or
sort of sends a to me a signal that this
is something that's got some momentum to
it and they're just trying to make sure
they fine-tune it as much as they can
put those up what about the sky judge
idea Charles what do you think of that
idea about its viability yeah the sky
judge I think is I would be surprised if
if that gets done now because I feel
like the league and and the officials
aren't quite prepared for it you know I
know
Troy Vincent talks about sort of having
the officiating pipeline and having
great people there for it and not
feeling like it was quite ready for it
yet and I would actually say that the
the P I flagged rule falling apart last
year on the field during the course of
the season has taught them maybe a
little bit of a lesson about if we don't
think we're fully prepared for for
something like this yet let's let's not
do it because you know I think Troy
Vincent probably put it best where he
said look officials should be faceless
mechanisms in a game that help the game
run smoothly they should become part of
the game and what the narrative is
surrounding the product and if the sky
judge if they don't have it completely
nailed down and they don't feel like
they have the proper officials to take
the sky judge positions for all the
games then it's going to become a
problem and and that's kind of what
happened what's a the pass interference
Flags last year and what happened and
didn't happen and the next thing you
know we're all talking about our around
every single week exactly I think they
kind of learn though yeah I agree with
you Charles it doesn't really rectify it
just depends on how much gumption does
the league have for it right I mean how
empowered is this going to be you know
Albert Breer brought brought up again
how people thought this was a fix for
what ailed the league would pass
interference last year and I told him
that the what he was throwing out in
terms of the theory for that what he's
hearing from people saying that sounded
exactly why what the league was saying
and people were in favor of making pass
interference reviewable we're saying
before the season and then when it
actually came time to put it into
practice it was just really a flop
there's no other way to describe it that
this doesn't fix it he says however
making the official part of the
officiating crew would change that that
the politics of the of the issue would
be removed because you know it's
somebody who's physically there and part
of the crew
right and it but I think that also makes
it the complication I think that's sort
of what Troy Vincent was talking about
with the pipeline is do you have the
body you know do you have the expertise
and the are you prepared for it you know
can you you know or are you gonna have
on I think when you when you looked at
the pass interference it was sort of the
uneven nature of it right as you started
to see hey this is like a judgment
situation and it's changing you know
some situations it wasn't working much
but then there were certain situations
where someone would throw a flag and get
the intended consequence that they
expected and then you'd sit there and go
well okay I'm comparing this against
fifty other flags that were thrown and
didn't work why why is you know the
uneven nature becomes the problem and I
think that's part of what the league and
and you know everyone who's sitting in
Park Amman and talking about the
officiating is like well as soon as
there's something that's off kilter that
immediately becomes something that we as
me I mean myself you know and others
like me end up hammering on every single
weekend with social media it just
becomes an echo chamber and that's the
last thing the league wants to walk into
again senior NFL reporter of Yahoo
Sports Charles Robinson here on the Rich
Eisen show what walked me through the
minicamp conversation the league really
just doesn't want to put dates on
anything until it has to and there was
some pushback from the league on your
reporting about dates being discussed
for minicamp being targeted the the 15th
of June or as late as the 27th I give
you the floor on all that
yeah the union president - JC Treader
you know came out on on Twitter and kind
of pushed back on it - and I so I think
people what they need to understand
about the report is it's what I tried to
lay out here is we're sort of we have
these steps and and the league is
looking at these steps and they would
like to get head coaches back into
facilities next week what I was told was
sort of conservatively maybe the end of
next week
and you know they feel like alright
let's see what happens in California was
gavin newsom we have these state
governments that are now getting to the
point now where we can get the the
structural operations of all the
football clubs up and running again
and once we get coaches in then can we
have a conversation about in some way
shape or form squeaking in getting some
players into the facility before the
break before the normal break that would
happen before training camp
now this camp as JC Trotter point
pointed out there was a negotiated cap
between the Union and and the league in
terms of the end of the virtual
offseason program which is June 26 now
from what I understand these are all
discussions that are fluid they can
still be in terms of hey if the league
wants to go to the Union say you know
what we've got sort of everybody up and
running we'd like to have some sort of
voluntary situation to bring guys in not
necessarily make it a mandatory minicamp
but maybe a voluntary mini camp where a
Tom Brady if you want to be out there
thrown to guys come do it in the
facility with the coaches or Lamar
Jack's and if you're out there working
with guys come do it in the facility you
know with coaches so we can all sort of
start to get on the same page here you
know I think that's the next iteration
of this conversation and there were
dates I know the league has said look we
haven't put hard dates on anything but I
you know I had two sources who flat-out
said to me the same date independent of
each other
they mentioned June 15th which didn't
sound as doable tither them but the June
27th date I have no idea why was the
27th and not the 26th or but it sounded
like though later in June there was like
this idea that maybe once we get coaches
in we can start to talk about getting
some sort of abridged form of getting
some players back into the into the fold
just before that break and I think
people have to understand - it gives the
the league an element a little bit of a
soft opening because they have to
prepare for how are we gonna do all of
us once training camp comes and it's
mandatory for everybody to show up maybe
if we get a collection of individuals
and now we start to look at the
protocols we need to get them into the
building that helps us form some sort of
guardrails for when training camps
coming on so if they delay that to June
and shouldn't we just assume that
training camps are not going to start on
time I mean at what point do we do we
just
call it out for what we're potentially
seeing right here Charles if I to me if
you're bringing in players at the end of
June you know if there's some sort of a
soft minicamp
and and it's whether it's you know I
would I would suggest that would likely
be involuntary or voluntary excuse me
yeah that it would be hard to believe
you're getting players and at the end of
June and then all of a sudden you're
opening you know training camp the
second or third week of July depending
on obviously which teams opening first
but the everything is so fluid right now
every and that's what everybody kept
telling me is I was working on this was
we're an uncharted territory here you're
trying to nail us down on exactly what
the protocols are the steps we're gonna
take literally figuring out one step at
a time and then going okay once that's
in the books now we start to look at the
next one
they have no idea we has no idea when
when training camps will open I think
the only thing the league can agree upon
is they wish owners would stop going on
CNBC and talking on Hannity last night
yeah Bob craft went on Fox News last
night right yeah you know even Ross
David Tepper I mean they've had the week
keeps asking owners and general managers
and everybody please we're trying to
have one unified voice here and when
people step out and say things we're
still trying to negotiate every point of
the process with the Union which is why
JC Treader comes out and says what he
says I have no doubt when I called some
of the Union I'm like hey I'm like
what's going on here like you know I got
JC Treader coming at me on Twitter and
someone from the Union said to me look
man I'm pretty sure JC had players
hitting him up saying wait a minute
we're gonna do mini camps now like when
did that happen and as I said to the
person you know it's in the story there
you guys have to sign off on anything
nothing set until you guys all agree on
it you know so I think that's part of
the reason is that the you know the
league's like everybody stopped talking
out of concert let us figure this out
with the Union so we can continue to
stuff this forward we have a lot of
things to think about what about where
we can just jump straight to Train sure
what about the finances
Charles in the same way that we're
seeing baseball struggle yeah there's no
question about it has that been has that
been hammered out that the league and
the players know what the finances would
be for a season that they're gonna plan
on having in full but with no fans
revenue would be obviously removed from
that I mean or is that coming to the NFL
too so what's interesting to me
everyone's talking about force majeure
like you know if the league the
collective bargaining agreement
depending on how you interpret it is hey
once the season kicks off the union's
can have the stance that hey players are
getting paid like this is the their
salary year kicks in everyone's getting
paid for for whatever you're on the hook
for over the course of the season once
once we play a regular-season game I
think the bigger question now is or at
least one of the big questions that
looms is sort of how will the cap be
affected it's it's derived from revenue
and stiffer Avenue dips with fans not
showing up you know shouldn't the cap
technically withdraw and I've asked a
couple of teams about you know what are
you talking about like you you clearly
are still trying to do contracts and
extensions and there's all this
uncertainty
I think what's interesting is you have
some teams that believe what's going to
end up happening is there's gonna be a
flat cap in 2021 that's a the Union and
the NFL are gonna figure out a way to
negotiate out a cap that doesn't rise
but doesn't fall and and then somehow
the money that they take you know so say
it would have dipped you know twenty
million dollars per team next season
they they flatten it out they take that
twenty million dollars and they spread
it out over the length of the collective
bargaining agreement so you're
essentially robbing Peter to pay Paul
down the line and and that way you're
you're keeping teams from having this
recession in the cap that could wreak
havoc on their rosters now I think even
a flat cap it's gonna reap some havoc oh
yeah but it's pretty clear they're
already talking about you know how to
keep this from rolling back the Union
doesn't want the Kaptur rollback I think
a lot of NFL owners don't want the
captain necessarily rollback
particularly ones that have
you know cap heavy roster you know he's
already pressed up against it and
there's not a single there's not a
single planner of rosters not a single
one that thought in a million years the
salary cap in the NFL would do anything
but go up not a single one yeah so I
know that's down the line I'm just
trying to figure out if we're gonna see
at some point the conversation that the
folks in baseball are struggling with
right now or maybe the NBA and the NHL
is doing behind the scenes a little bit
better than what baseball is would be
coming soon to the NFL I I think that
the NFL is very aware of the negative
impact that the negotiations have had on
on baseball right now and I think the
Union is very aware of the negative
impact that negotiations of that on on
the product and you know moving forward
i I think the only way at least when I
talk to particularly people from the
Union the only way they think that that
ends up being you know something that
has to be a conversation is if we get to
the point where we're gonna start a
racing games or there's a chance the
season doesn't happen and I still think
almost everyone I talked to has the
Steven Ross you know what vantage point
it's gonna happen like we believe the
seasons gonna happen now it's just
figuring out exactly how it's gonna
happen and I think I frankly think that
bridge was crossed when the league comes
out and they bring out medical experts
and they bring out Jeff Miller and they
start talking about hey we know we're
gonna have positive tests it's gonna
happen like we're but we're gonna have a
plan in place to deal with positive
tests to me you're you're thinking
beyond hey we just have to shut down
where you're thinking of of all the trap
doors that exist and how to to deal with
those so that you can have a season in
place as best you possibly can and what
about the idea Charles a few more quick
hitters with you the idea that there's a
helmet that's being discussed to be
outfitter I do believe the the Union
might have made this public too that
they're looking at a face mask that
would be covered with n95 material like
the surgical
mask covering on on helmets facemask so
every player would be masked on the
field as they're playing yeah they're
flood they're flooding the zone with
with in terms of everything they're
looking at so it's not you know we're in
terms of the player safety it's just not
like so I I had a conversation with one
team because I do a training camp tour
and I said hey you know do you think I
just won't be allowed because you know
I'd be bouncing around from city to city
and I can't be somebody quarantined like
how would you deal with that and he
literally went through a litany of he's
like hey you know what you're not gonna
have locker room access you're not gonna
have this you're not gonna have that
here all the different things that are
going to change and then he started to
talk about as you said things on the
field like hey we're looking at
potential equipment situations we're
talking about hey you know the way that
you know players are exposed to other
personnel on the field people on the
chain gang all these different things
like I said they're flooding the zone
with every you know aspect of what can
we change to potentially protect players
and give them that extra level of of
comfort I again I don't know you know
we'll see how this works out I it's
interesting because in Dallas there's
going to be a an offensive line camp
that's supposed to take place and in
July and I'd love to talk to you know
some of these offensive linemen who it's
50 60 snaps a game it's literally your
job to bash yourself up against the guy
in front of you and how are you gonna
prevent getting spit on blood on you
know every possible you know
scenario that you can imagine you
wouldn't want to do and why you social
distance you're gonna you're gonna
abandon that 50 60 times in game so and
the last one for you how does the dak
situation play in all this I mean if the
cap is flat right or or I mean he's
still on sign man I mean this is crazy
how he has been allowed to get to this
point or I guess he's forced his way to
this point I don't know where it all
sits but middle of July this is gonna
have to be decided what's happening here
what do you think Charles yeah I mean it
has the hallmarks
of her cousins although I think it's a
little bit different because you know
Washington the reticence with Kirk I
mean there were a lot of different
reasons you know I heard a lot of hey
the arrows pointed flats not pointed up
on Kirk there's a reason we don't want
it but where's the cowboys top the
bottom really everybody says we want
them blonde a Sinai means our guy he's
our cornerstone they just keep fighting
over this for years of control versus
five years of control
I think I'm of the mind the people who
say hey deadlines spur deals I'm they're
like I think between July and July 15th
is probably when you're going to see the
most traction I think if it doesn't get
done I think he plays this shot on the
tag I think he'll go the full way with
the leverage he'll play it out and and
force them to tag him again and then get
to the point where they have to make a
very very difficult painful decision on
him down the line but I wonder and I
don't I'm not when I say this I'm purely
speculating but I wonder if because of
the uncertainty going forward with the
cap in other situations whether or not
Todd France and see a look at dak and go
you know what we have a pretty good deal
on the table we're pretty close let's
see if we can figure out some middle
ground in terms of the financial number
versus the four years in the five years
and let's really try to get this done
because we don't know what's going to
happen next year with next year's cap or
this season and all these different
things right I mean I think that the
environment might actually help the
cowboys in this scenario well I mean
look Charles and then there's last
question for the the $64,000 question
that I asked everybody as they come on
here and I get asked it all the time I'm
no expert in public health neither are
you but I think we can see that at least
the threat may not be different but
maybe the tolerance to deal with it or
the confidence in being able to deal
with it is definitely stronger now than
it was say draft night that's for sure
and the circumstances may have changed
on the ground we don't know because the
virus keeps shifting it seems and you
know Fred I keep reading articles that
say you know it could go
a or doesn't there's no shine I mean
that's kind of crazy what I'm reading
about it but you know reading the tea
leaves do you think we've got a season
you do believe we've got a season yes or
no I do I think we will have a season i
I think the as you said the $64,000
question though is going to be how the
league reacts to infection because as
you said it's sort of shifting sands
right now and I expect that will happen
into the fall I listen to the same
medical experts you do I mean it seems
to you can get any opinion wrong if you
look for it hard enough and but I think
when the league comes out and says we
are preparing as if people will get
infected I would be surprised given the
number of personnel involved in in the
leagues the thousands of players we're
talking about and then all the
surrounding personnel that there won't
be infection that occurs once training
camp starts or you know when people
reconvene it I think there will be
infection in the fall and then to me
that how is the lead prepared at that
moment to ultimately deal with this so
that that's the make-or-break moment
because I don't think that will I don't
think we'll have to go into the regular
season when that moment happens I think
it's going to end up happening you know
once we get all back together in
training camp someone's going to test
positive and then there's going to have
to be a pivot point where we figure out
exactly how the league deals with that
Charles appreciate the time man we'll
get you on further on down the line and
just to check in with you and kick the
tires on your on your knowledge and
hopefully we do have a playing season
absolutely I appreciate it always my
pleasure thank you that's Charles
Robinson of Yahoo Sports exclamation
point is silent by the way
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here